FOR THE VANCOUVER CANUCKS AND
LOOKING FOR HIS FIRST
THE DRAW AND
BOES THE SIDE AND IT
IS SHOT WIDED
MUCH AND HERE JUULSEN HAD MOVEDD
AHEAD TO TEXIER WITH HUGHES
TAKING
AND HE LOSES A EDGE, C HUGHES.
BACK.
>> John S.: YOU CANHAT
>> John S.: AND JOHN JUST TO
CLEAR UP THE THROAT GUARD
MYSTERY IT IS BACK AND SO AWAY D
AWAY, M
>> John G.: WELL, BROCK BOESER,
HE C FOUR-ON-FOUR PLAY
AND THE GOAL, FOUR
POINTS NOW IN HIS LAST EIGHT MEA
TIME BUT ELIAS PETTERSSON COULD
NOT MAKE THAT PASS IN
ELIAS PETTERSSON.
HUGHES, MYERS THIS TIME, UNDER
PRESSURE AND HUGHESD AND FOR TH,
JUST FIVE SHOTS FOR THEM S TO H,
QUINN HUGHES COMING OUT FRONT, D
THAT TIME, COULD NOT TAKE ITACR!
[ Horn ]
[ Applause ]
CLEAN AND
HORVAT, A DANGEROUS LITTLE PASS,
BACK.STRAND,
FINDS IT, WERENSKI CHIPPING IT
WIDE WITH LESS THAN TEN TO